in rotterdam they're doing repairs after
a night of violence
and also stealing themselves for the
potential of more to come
here and across the netherlands three
nights of protest against covert
regulations
have been followed by violent clashes
with the police
the dutch are facing their first curfew
since the second world war
but compared to many nations lockdown
restrictions here are not especially
onerous
masks are not mandatory outdoors you can
have a visitor in your home every day
and yet somehow frustration and anger
are boiling over it breaks my heart
really because um
you know we i uh we're trying to
we're trying just like anyone else on
the planet we're just trying to have a
harmonious life the most of us they have
the right
to do that but not make the
shops uh uh i almost i tell it not to
attack no
no i take two shots that's not good
i think that can happen happening again
tonight i think
around us the scars of last night's
clashes
so here they are clearing up after one
night of violence
and preparing for the possibility of
another one
and the pattern that's developing is
quite clear what starts as a protest
about
curfews and coveted regulations descends
into simple vandalism
today the supermarket was being boarded
up and here's why
last night it was attacked smashed
and looted by a mob and there were
similar scenes across the netherlands
fireworks and rocks thrown at the police
tear gas and water cannon coming back in
the other direction
parliament will debate this outbreak of
violence tomorrow
today schools were closed early and a
nation was fretting
the netherlands is a country that prides
itself on consensus
and calm the moment it's got neither
adam parsons sky news rotterdam